[Music]
a very good evening you're watching the
press preview it's our first look at
what is on sunday's front pages and
tonight we'll see what's making the
headlines with the journalist and author
rachel shabby and the leader writer at
the daily telegraph tim stanley great to
see you both again we'll chat in a
moment uh we'll have a look first though
at the front pages for you starting with
the observer which says boris johnson is
expected to make the head of the civil
service the fall guy over partygate in a
desperate effort to save his own job
the sunday times claims an ambulance
trust in the northeast of england has
been caught covering up damning evidence
about deaths linked to mistakes by
paramedics
the transport secretary grant shaps has
told the sunday telegraph the government
is planning a way to break the
stranglehold trade unions have on the
public
here's the sunday express in an
interview with the paper the education
secretary nadim zahawi says every people
in england will be eligible for free
personal tuition under new plans
colleen rooney is on the front of the
sunday mirror which claims she told a
friend she will win the so-called wag of
the christie libel trial with rebecca
vardy celebrated with a cup of tea
and the star says the ukrainian army has
rescued a russian dog trained to attack
but retrained him to work for them
don't forget by scanning the qr code you
can see on screen during the program you
can check out the front pages of
sunday's papers while you watch us
chatting about them and i'm joined now
by rachel shabby and tim stanley lots to
uh discuss this saturday evening uh
rachel why don't we start with the front
of the
observer
lots of uh discussion in the papers
about the su grey report of course due
out
this week potentially as soon as tuesday
potentially i say because there may be
yet another delay we'll perhaps talk
about that in a moment but the observer
saying that the prime minister could
sacrifice uh a top official in order to
save himself
well indeed um it looks like he is
planning to sacrifice the senior head of
the civil service simon casey you'll
remember simon case was the was the man
who was initially supposed to lead
the su grey investigation but he had to
step down
after um
concerns that he was actually at some of
the parties that was being investigated
which seemed to say it all but yes boris
johnson is now scrabbling around uh
looking for someone to take the hit
instead of him as his his nature as has
been a feature of his political career
and um some people have speculated that
actually the reason case is still
imposed is precisely for this purpose
precisely so that he can be scapegoated
and thrown under the bus in this way
there's a source in this in this uh
article with the observer saying that
actually the
sugar report is pretty scathing
um about the culture that was allowed to
develop
um in downing street uh and while all
around around party game um and it is
you know it's supposed to it's predicted
to be you know
really quite fierce and so
uh it is necessary for johnson to find
someone to shunt the blame on to enable
in order to preserve his own career is
the theory according to the story yeah i
mean do you think rachel i mean it was
pretty damning when when uh the prime
minister got that fine uh obviously but
do you think even though we know he's
not going to get any more fines
this report could be even more damaging
for him than getting getting that first
fight
you know i think it will be damaging but
i don't think it will damage him because
you know he's he's he's got the perfect
get out now where he can say well
the police didn't think it was serious
enough to find me more than once even
though you know he was at six of those
parties deemed uh to have broken the law
he was only fined for one of them so
he's got the perfect get out hasn't he
um so i suspect that you know he is
going to get away with this and you know
he's made a career out of getting away
with things so this
would just be the latest one yeah okay
let's get tim's thoughts then as we have
a look at the uh sun page two quite like
this headline will sue gray um two
points then tim really first uh simon
case do you think he'll be a scapegoat
uh and secondly
a lot of the officials are very worried
understandably about being named in this
report
and there could be legal action and that
could mean that we don't get the report
this week it could be
a another further delay
both of those great pun by the way both
of those of course are speculative
because we don't exactly know what's in
the report so in the in the case of
simon case course this is going to be
punilicious tonight isn't it
in the case of simon case we don't know
if the prime minister's going to be able
to deflect blame onto him because we
we don't know what kind of blame is
attributed to the prime minister uh in
the case of whether or not people will
end up suing but it was reported uh
later late this week
that senior officials are going to be
named
and if they are then it wouldn't
surprise me if they took some sort of
legal action of course junior officials
who've been fined during all of this
don't have the recourse to calling a
lawyer and because they're relatively
poorly paid the impact of all this upon
their career and upon their finances is
actually bigger i would say that boris
johnson's chances of surviving party
great gate have gotten stronger the more
that it has grown the wider that the net
has been cast the less it is perceived
to be about him and his responsibility
and more ideas about a vague culture in
downing street that i suspect you'd find
in most large organizations even during
a pandemic
and of course the the accusations have
spread not just
throughout government not just
throughout whitehall but they've also
trickled over into the opposition
benches and right now someone else
failed facing actual legal jeopardy in
regards to partying during covet or
allegedly partying is kirstarma
so partygate by actually metastasizing
in this way i think has taken some of
the pressure off of boris johnson and i
i think it's very hard to match the
scenario under which backbenchers have
put up with so much in the last few
weeks and who are so desperate to move
on to other issues i think it's very
unlikely they're going to be sending
letters to the head of the 1922
committee demanding that the prime
minister go okay we spent quite a lot on
this topic so i do want to move on um if
that's okay rachel moving on to uh uh
events down under front of the uh
telegraph labour's albinisi albo as they
call him in australia vows to end
climate wars he's the new prime minister
of australia um what do you make of this
um the center left strikes again this is
the first win for australian labour
party in 10 years and he won on a
platform of change interestingly the
greens and the independents did well in
this election also
um it does seem to be an election that
was fought on the basis of climate
emergency and also the cost of living
and so parties that actually
speak to that that talk about solutions
for that and um this labor leader did
lean quite heavily into
um investing in climate uh in renewable
energy sources etc and tackling the
climate emergency
by contrast with the outgoing prime
minister australian prime minister scott
morrison who you'll remember during the
bushfires of 2019 um denied the link uh
with the climate emergency whereas you
know climate science is quite clear that
these natural uh disasters and extreme
weather events are made
more frequent and more extreme by the
climate emergency so it does seem like
he was punished for his take on the
climate crisis where labour is being
rewarded for
actually having policies to want to deal
with it
okay same story uh in the
sun page two labour grabs power uh also
on the front page of the times are both
going with a photo of a man in his
trunks um and that is because of course
voting tim is compulsory in australia
and that means even if you're on the
beach or you've been for a swim you
still have to go and put your mark in
the ballot box
absolutely we usually have dogs at
polling stations that's the thing
everyone tweets about but australians
seem to have trunks of polling stations
that's their that's their thing
every every election uh is specific and
occurs under in a particular context in
the case of of this recent election uh
yes labour on the left are the winners
uh but albanesia has moved to the center
in order to be able to win uh also
you've seen a fracturing of politics
which has hurt both parties long term
the emergence of a green on party on the
left but also on the right scott
morrison the incumbent prime minister
was hurt by a sort of defection
of what you might
call goldsmith uh style environmentalist
conservatives under a so-called teal
coalition also running on women's rights
also running on women's
under-representation in politics also
running against corruption so this is
this is if rory stewart's sort of a
party basically but it was run by a
woman so the right had fractured as well
and the liberal environmentalist uh
conservatives had gone their own way and
split the vote so every election has
particular circumstances but undeniably
yeah this is a win for the alp who'll
probably form a green star coalition
like they have in germany
and it is partly about the cost of
living but rachel's absolutely right
it's also about climate and a change
that's taking place within australian
politics where it used to be thought
that if you were the friend of the fuel
if you were a friend of the
non-renewable industries then you
probably have an advantage in australian
politics things have tipped in the last
few years and it might now be uh that
you in order to enjoy an advantage you
have to be tough on climate change and
that may be felt in a change in policy
in the liberal party
very interesting okay we'll leave you
there for the moment thank you both uh
coming up after the break the
chancellor's been warned that a windfall
tax on energy companies won't solve the
cost of living crisis that we'll be
discussing that in a couple of minutes
[Music]
hello again part two of the press
preview tim and rachel still
with us rachel let's talk about the
windfall tax shall we the sunday
telegraph and the times putting it on
their front pages both taking a slightly
different take uh on it the telegraph
is saying that ministers are warning
sunac it's not the right way to go we
know brandon lewis sajd javid both say
they don't like the idea but the sunday
times
has got a line that the chancellor is
attracted by the idea of a sort of
pro-investment form of the windfall tax
different rates of tax depending on how
much a company was prepared to invest in
the uk
um do you think a windfall tax in some
form rachel is on the way
i don't know but i do know that it
should be and i do know that the type
the government's own internal polling
shows 80 percent of the population
support it as well look the objections
to the winform tax coming from the
conservatives are nonsense bunk
obfuscation it's because they
ideologically fundamentally don't
believe in windfall tax or higher rates
of tax on the highest earners now
they've said you've got um some minister
some mps and sources saying they think
that a win for tax is unconservative uh
there it is just pure ideology the
windfall tax will put 600 pounds into
the pockets of the households that need
it most uh labor proposed the windfall
tax as one way to get the potentially
500 000 extra kids who would fall into
poverty uh because of the spiraling cost
of living uh to avoid that taking place
winfor tax isn't the only thing the
government can do but it is striking
that it is absolutely nothing has
absolutely nothing
to cope with um what people are facing
these excruciating anxiety that people
are dealing with over spiraling
inflation um flatlining wages and the
stagnant economy
um
this government just looks out of touch
it looks like it doesn't care and it
looks like it doesn't know what to do
honestly it doesn't okay we're running
out time so tim i want your thoughts on
this uh the problem with the windfall
tax is first of all it is a
retrospective tax so uh the people who
made money uh didn't know it was coming
and then once they have made money they
then get hit by it so that's sort of
unethical really secondly it puts off
investment uh george osborne
experimented with a north sea windfall
tax in the early 2010s and the result
was that investment in north sea uh went
down so the government is worried that
it could take that give a little bit of
money back to the voters
but actually kill off the kind of
long-term investment in north sea gas
which you need if you're going to
increase production well
suggested that that wouldn't happen
didn't they
well this is the irony it started out as
a labor idea the tories initially said
well no to it on the assumption that the
companies would say it's a terrible
thing it'll put us off investment and
then one or two industry figures said
actually we wouldn't particularly mind
but as i said the historical experience
is rather different that what can seem
like a way of reducing pain in the short
term actually ends up getting passed on
to the consumer in the long run
particularly because it means the
production is being isn't being
increased and also don't forget that
governments governments across the world
are sending signals to the fossil fuel
companies who should be investing in
renewables anyway yeah so it doesn't it
doesn't surprise me that they they're
not particularly worried about money not
going into uh non-renewable investment
because they're being told it's not the
future